كان هذا المشهد يلخص حال اسرائيل كيف لا
وهي تسال عن جرائمها للمره الاولى امام
العالم ولم تجد نفسها في هذا الموقف من
قبل ما يجري في لهاي ضد دوله اليهود يعبر
عن مستوى منحط تصوروا هذا العبث النازيون
الجدد يتهموننا بالابا هذا عار هذه وقاحه
ايام او اسابيع قليله تفصلنا عن قرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه في دعوى الاباده
الجماعيه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا الدوله
ذاتها التي عانت من الاضطهاد وعاشت في ظل
نظام فصل عنصري شبه باسرائيل لكن هذا
النظام لم يدم لتقوم بعد تفكيكه دوله
بزعامه نيلسون منديلا القادم من السجن
والذي ربط الحريه في بلاده بحريه
الفلسطينيين وهذا ما جعل لهذه القيه رمزيه
ودلالات
[موسيقى]
كبيره عديل هاشم ابرز اعضاء فريق جنوب
افريقيا ذاع صيتها خلال مشاركتها في
المرافعات الخاصه بالشكوى ولفتت الانظار
ببلاغته في تقديم الحجج عرفت بنشاطها في
رفض الاستيطان والممارسات الاسرائيليه
عامه كما قادت العديد من الحملات القضائيه
والحقوق المهمه في مجال حقوق الانسان
عديله ليست وحدها الفريق القانوني لجنوب
افريقيا يضم ايضا وزير العدل وعددا من
اساتذه القانون والمحامين
البارزين
فهل ينجح هذا الفريق في تثبيت تهمه
الاباده على
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل